«Bonjour et bienvenue
sur La Chaine Parlementaire
de l'Assemblée nationale. "
" C'est pas trop fort ça ?
Bienvenue !
Comme ça,
ça va pas. "
" Merci de nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de Parlement Hebdo. "
" Bonjour à tous,
bienvenue sur LCP, il est 13h. "
" Où va la France ?
c'est le thème du débat du jour. "
" Bonsoir à tous !
Ravie de vous retrouver
à la une de Ça vous regarde, ce soir. "
" Ce soir Myriam, on va parler musique,
j'arrive tout de suite. "
" Clément Meric,
vous êtes salles des 4 Colonnes.
L'ambiance est un peu
électrique sur ce texte.
- Ah oui, comme je suis fier
d'être insulté...
- Un peu de calme mes chers collègues !
Un peu de calme !
- ... en me traitant
de populiste. "
" Je vais lever la séance,
je vous préviens ! "
" S'il vous plaît,
arrêtez de pousser des cris. "
" Peut-on encore parler
d'un moment de vérité aujourd'hui
lorsqu'il est question
d'une interview politique ?
C'est la question posée aujourd'hui
dans ce DébatDoc. "
" Vous êtes bien, vous êtes
vraiment bien sur LCP
la chaine qui, dit-on,
voit la politique en grand. "
" Le Contrat, c'est le nom
de cette émission. "
" Bonjour à tous, voilà
une belle idée d'entamer
cette journée avec nous
dans Politique Matin. "
" Alors évidemment vous vous demandez
mais qu'est-ce qu'elle trafique ?
Est-ce qu'on fait une émission
sur les fringues ou pas ?
Pas du tout !
Nous, on fait Déconfinés. "
" Bienvenue à Rembob'INA,
l'émission qui parcourt les archives
de l'INA, en tenue de gala. "
" C'est une chaine de qualité,
donc je suis content de la rejoindre. "
" - Je suis un vrai fan
de La Chaine Parlementaire.
J'ai commencé avec
la commission Outreau.
J'ai écouté à peu près
les deux tiers des débats.
Et depuis, je l'écoute
tous les après-midi au bureau.
L'écoute, parce que maintenant
je commence à reconnaître
les uns et les autres.
- Vous êtes un mordu !
- Je suis un mordu oui,
c'est bon ! "